I've been using the 16-inch MacBook Pro
for a whole year now and I want to share
how my experience has been my opinions
that have changed over time what has
improved and what we're still having
issues with that may make you want to
wait for the updated three nanometer
models now everybody was expecting new
MacBooks coming out this month but no
Tim Cook has officially said that their
lineup is set for the holiday season so
we're not getting any new MacBooks so
why would this happen well Vadim has
been talking about three nanometer chips
coming to the 14 and 16 inch Mac Pros
for a long time even when everybody was
disagreeing with them but recently a lot
of Publications started to agree and
Mark German one of the most accurate
leakers has just put out a report saying
that Apple's likely waiting for three
nanometer and it is gonna be worth the
wait now along with my follow-up review
I will also get into this and why and
how it could be better and if it's worth
waiting or if you just buy a discounted
16 or 14 inch MacBook Pro on Amazon and
some of these prices are insane now the
14 inches aren't that good of a deal
like you get about 120 bucks off a new
one but looking at a refurbished one you
can get one for 500 off 1500 bucks which
is crazy and Amazon has a three-month
return policy if you don't like anything
about it but the 16 inch models a brand
new one you can get over 320 dollars off
but refurbished it is shockingly over
720 off on a 16 inch machine which is
insane that's a killer value and after
using it for a year I can't believe you
can get such a nice machine for that
price now what has stood out to me and
what hasn't well the first one is
promotion these machines refresh the
screens at up to 120 FPS but I will say
it is not that noticeable at least to me
now on the iPhones it has made a major
difference reference on iPads it's an
even more shocking difference but on the
max when I use an empty MacBook Air it
is seems just as smooth not a huge
difference but what has been is that
mini LED display you get such great
contrast in HDR blacks that are almost
pure black the highlights pop out like
crazy with 1600 nits and comparing it to
an LCD display in the past if you have
an older MacBook or Windows laptop I
mean the difference is shocking and
contrast you're gonna get all that gray
there that's been such a big plus now
with that if you're somebody that uses
your laptop in a bright room or Outdoors
I've been using that Vivid app when I
need to punch it up and allows you to
hit the full 1000 nits and that is so so
helpful and something that is just a
major upgrade compared to the previous
machines one of my favorite things about
this machine that I keep being reminded
of is just how quiet it is it is pretty
much silent even though internally it
has those two fans they are quite large
especially on a 16 inch model and no
matter what I'm doing it is almost
always completely silent so you don't
need an empty MacBook Air now when I
picked up my I9 one that I still have
from before that thing constantly kicks
up and all the windows laptops that
we've had and we test those will kick up
the fans even if we're installing a
program it's so annoying and it's such a
nice upgrade to have that now the other
thing is battery life that was such a
game changer compared to the Intel
models literally double the battery life
if you're really pushing the machine but
I will say over the last year there were
times that I have been disappointed with
the battery life of my 16 inch and I'm
going to get into that a bit more later
in the video now thankfully we can fast
charge up to 50 percent in a half hour
and that brings me to our sponsor Koval
and their 140 watt charger with the new
SPD 3.1 Tech that charges a 16 inch to
56 in just 30 minutes while also having
a 25 watt USB type a port all for only
54 dollars after using the coupon the
makers of Koval manufacture for anchor
and ravpower in use can 3 Tech to keep
things cool and for charge protection
while having smaller footprint than
Apple's 140 watt go ahead and check it
out using the link down below now with
that we have magsafe charging now this
has been awesome everybody's happy that
Apple brought this back but I will have
to say that personally I'm not using it
as much as I expected because you can
only use this charger for the MacBook
now I still need lightning for my
airpods airpods Max iPhone and also USB
type c for iPad so I'm trying to stick
with less cables using USB type c and it
would have been great if Apple you know
adds this to more devices like the
iPhone now some of you guys may remember
that I I returned my 16 inch MacBook Pro
because the 14 inch offered so much
power in such a small footprint
something we have never been able to
have before and I loved the size and
weight of it so what am I doing
reviewing a 16 inch one year later well
over the last year I found myself being
frustrated at times with a 14 inch
especially when I'm doing productive
tasks like photo editing and video
editing now for photo editing the 14
inch isn't bad because you don't have
that much going on and that is okay but
on the 16 inch it is nice to have the
larger screen but for video editing
specifically it does make a big
difference and it does speed up your
work while having the 16 inch model so
even though I don't like that Apple made
it thicker they made it heavier having
the larger screen is very nice and that
is just something that we can't really
beat physics with even though Apple
silicon is so efficient gives us so much
performance even in a MacBook Air you
have to have a large screen in order to
also help out in other ways so maybe
apple one day give us that rumored
15-inch MacBook Air that would be great
but for now we're stuck choosing you
know one laptop over a different one and
most people unlike me being a YouTuber
and I have to have each model you guys
see that stack well you make one choice
so after last year if I had to choose
only just one I would have to go with
this 16 inch even though I do find
myself sometimes picking up the M2
MacBook Air because they're so nice for
regular tasks with that there are some
other things that are great about having
the 16 inch model now the one that
stands out to me even now a year later
are the speakers Apple put insane
speakers in both the 14 and 16 inch
model but they were not similar at all
the 16 inch has much bigger speaker
enclosures and the bass the loudness it
just defeats every other laptop out
there even much thicker heavier Windows
laptops and I'm still surprised by how
great it sounds and when I use the empty
MacBook Air even at the better speakers
it is just not even close so if you're
somebody that watches movies you watch
videos you play music I mean the 16 inch
is insanely good and now what really
hasn't improved or what's still a
disappointment well the first thing is
optimization now Apple just released the
latest version of Final Cut stating
they're gonna have faster exporting for
video with apple silicon but when I
tested out exporting Asia 265 like we do
every single day it wasn't any faster
than the numbers that we got almost a
year ago now sure these machines are
already super fast but I'm talking about
optimizations over time when we looked
at the performance of the graphics
themselves it did not scale linearly and
we didn't hit the 80 000 or 79 000 if we
would have scaled from the smaller M1
Max chips and that is disappointing
because at the start we were talking
about optimizations it's going to get
better but he was saying that but it
really hasn't Apple mentioned that the
ammo Max for example shows up as one GPS
you don't have SLI scaling issues but
when we look at the facts we do have
that we are not having completely linear
scaling now we can also see that with
the wattage that is used when we're
using the graphics we're not hitting the
60 watts that Apple talked about and
because of that the performance doesn't
match up to like an RTX 3080 if they
showed off on screen so should you wait
for the three nanometer chips what
difference will that make and what
features will we get well first off we
know that it's not going to come out in
early January or February it's going to
be mid-march so that's a long wait and
with that one thing we're going to see
are lower temperatures now the 16 inch
didn't have that many issues with
thermals except for in one instance
where the 24 query mode Max would
actually beat out the 32 core in a 16
inch other than that though it was fine
but the 14 inch a 32 core M1 Max would
actually run slower if you really push
it compared to a 16 inch base model now
three nanometer is going to use a lot
less power it's going to have less heat
so we're gonna have less thermal
throttling and better performance now on
the other side what we're going to have
is better battery life if you take a
look at that 16 inch with M1 Max it
drains a ton of power when we're pushing
all of those cores and three nanometer
is a lot more efficient now with that
this MacBook the reason I'm not always
happy is when you're really pushing it
it's better than before but it sucks a
lot of power and then when you're not
using it very heavily even though it
does get good battery life it is not
amazing whereas with the M2 Chip it has
those new efficiency cores that are so
powerful and so little power that could
do a lot with that and then if you
enable the low power mode it goes down
to less than two Watts for the CPU and
even less for the GPU allowing it to
have insane battery life but still be
quite fast whereas with the M1 Pro and
M1 Max chips they only drop down to
about 15 watts for the CPU barely any
difference now the new three nanometer
models they will have the super
efficient cores even more efficient ones
and so if you don't need all the
performance you will get absolutely
jaw-dropping battery life I'm talking 20
hour battery life on a machine which is
just absolutely crazy so that is a great
reason to wait now there's also a chance
that we could have face ID in the
MacBook we've shown code in the beta
versions for face ID I love that on
Windows it'd be great to have but they
also have to deal with having such a
thin display and being able to fit that
in so it needs more Tech and then of
course maybe 5G support as well which is
what I would like to be able to have
data anywhere you're at it's very very
convenient but with that said it's gonna
be a weight possibly another six months
or so and we also have reports from the
leaker that actually showed off the Mac
Studio before it was announced saying
that the price hikes are going to go up
10 to 30 percent in different places
outside of the US just like they have
with iPhones with iPads so if you're
there you'll know that this is going to
get a lot more expensive and is it worth
waiting and spending extra money and
potentially maybe here in the states
that might go up as well and with these
absolutely insane deals on Amazon where
you can score a 14 inch base for 1400
bucks refurbished or about 1700 for a 16
inch uh it's just if you don't need the
absolute best performance or the
absolute best battery life I would say I
would pick one up right now overall it's
an insanely great machine better than
pretty much everything else out there
and you'll get to use it and save some
dime you guys let me know your thoughts
down in the comment section below click
that Circle above to subscribe check out
one of those great videos there's been
Max and I'll see you in the next one
[Music]